In some parts of Asia, pointing the soles of your feet at someone...
...is seen as extreme rudeness and could easily get you into trouble.
This is also true in Russia as well as parts of the Middle East.
That's why when George W. Bush almost took a shoe to the head...
...from an angry Iraqi journalist,...
...it was more symbolic than it was an act of violence.
A shoe was a dirty weapon aimed at the highest...
...and most esteemed point of the body.
In countries such as Thailand and China, putting your feet up on a chair...
...and certainly any place near to where someone might put their head...
...is seen as very disrespectful.
The foot in most of Asia is seen as dirty and the head is sacred.
If you are planning to travel to Asia,...
...bear this in mind lest you rankle the locals.
In parts of Asia, be careful when you write something down...
...for someone as writing in red ink is seen as a curse.
This is because in some Asian cultures, red ink was reserved for messages...
...applying to the deceased.
Filling in an official form in red, maybe even an arrival card,...
...in countries such as Taiwan, Korea, Japan or Thailand...
...is seen as bad form and perhaps a very bad omen.
Red is reserved for the dead in an official environment.